everyone loves Disney's family of
superheroes but sometimes the world of
The Incredibles leaves us with lots of
questions
that's where fan theories come in check
out these 10 biggest fan theories about
the Incredibles that make total sense
extra extra read all about it The
Incredibles was one of the best Disney
Pixar movies of all time it's all about
a world where superheroes or supers are
real you know how it goes though
whenever superheroes fight supervillains
they leave destruction in their wake
whole cities get destroyed it's a hot
mess
wait a second that's the Avengers we're
talking about The Incredibles but it was
pretty much the same thing the supers
always caused chaos when they tried to
save the day
so the government forced them into
hiding The Incredibles is all about mr.
incredible and his family he is married
to Elastigirl and they have three
adorable children with powers but mr.
incredible just isn't happy being a
regular guy in the first movie he gets
lured into becoming a super again from
his arch-nemesis syndrome syndrome aka
buddy used to be his biggest fan but mr.
incredible told him as a kid to leave
him alone but syndrome just wants to be
a super after the incredible family
saves the day super start getting a good
reputation again in a second movie
Elastigirl is recruited to help rebuild
the image of supers everywhere but
sometimes we are left with more
questions than answers let's take a look
at the fan theories that explain a lot
about the world of the Incredibles
[Music]
parents have extra powers we know from
the movies that supers powers show up
when they are young but they don't show
up right away in the first movie no one
knows for sure if Jack Jack has powers
and then in the second movie he has a
ton he might be the strongest Incredible
yet but somehow Bob and Helen totally
know what their kids powers are going to
be how do we know that well let's take a
look at each of the kids violin is the
oldest park kid she has the power of
invisibility she can also create force
fields color is divided into different
spectrums the ultraviolent spectrum
cannot be seen by human eyes violets
ultraviolet and guess what color her
force fields are that's right they are
violet then there's - - means to run
fast and what is his super power he has
super speed well what about Jack Jack
is a regular name right wrong jack-jack
has a ton of powers he can do a little
bit of everything you might say he's a
jack-of-all-trades get it this ability
to sense their children's powers was
pointed out by redditor super blue it
totally makes sense to us psychology 101
this next theory requires a bit of an
understanding of psychology a famous
psychologist named Sigmund Freud came up
with the idea that personalities have
three parts
there is the it'd which is all of our
instincts it's unconscious and what we
are born knowing then there is ego ego
is reality it's shaped by society and
works with it to seek out pleasure and
avoid pain then there is super ego
super-ego is all about controlling our
impulses from it especially those that
society doesn't allow okay now that
class is over how does this relate to
the Incredibles well all three kids
relate to one of these parts of the
personality Jack Jack is it he is a baby
and acts totally on instinct he has
angry outbursts and just tries to get
what he needs
- his ego he is still very impulsive but
he uses reality to make decisions violet
is super-ego
she's older and has learned how to deal
with it and ego she controls and
protects it or Jack Jack and she
channels dashes energy just like
super-ego channels ego bring this up to
your psychology teacher and see what she
says mind control
remember Mirage she is the assistant to
syndrome in the first movie she lures
mr. incredible to syndromes lair
she makes him think he is being used to
stop a top-secret experiment turned
villain but really it's a trap from
syndrome Mirage also acts really
attracted to mr. incredible they are
definitely flirting throughout the movie
is that part of her act or was it real
Mirage knows what syndrome is up to but
then she has a change of heart when
things get really bad she decides to
help The Incredibles defeat her boss her
change of heart seems to come out of
nowhere if she's been working for the
bad guy why did she suddenly switch
sides
when theory suggests that syndrome was
controlling her mind he has a ton of
Technology and is really intelligent in
fact some people think his super
intelligence is his superpower and that
he is really a super what if syndrome
was controlling her mind she switches
sides once he leaves the lair he's no
longer there to control her that would
Emily explain why her change happened so
suddenly syndromes house in Incredibles
to the PAR family home gets destroyed
for a while they stay in a motel but
then Winston Deborah lets them stay in
one of the many houses he owns
apparently the one they get was owned by
an eccentric billionaire the original
owner wanted to get in and out
undetected that sure sounds like
something a villain would want this
house is full of state-of-the-art
technology syndrome had built his lair
to be controlled by remote and he didn't
install many safety features just like
this house he assumes that only he would
be using it and the water feature
separates into a pathway just like the
lava did on syndromes Island it totally
fits his design MO plus his home is
close to the city where mr. incredible
is from that's also where Syndrome grew
up it totally fits do you think the new
house belonged to Syndrome let us know
what you think in the comments the Jimmy
Neutron link for kickin it old school
for this next Theory Jimmy Neutron was a
cartoon that aired from 2002 to 2006 it
was about a boy genius who made all
sorts of awesome technology he had a
robotic dog named Godard Jimmy had a
tendency to think very highly of himself
and his inventions go awry which causes
all sorts of chaos in fact he looks a
lot like another boy genius we know
buddy
from The Incredibles Jimmy is obsessed
with getting praise and is way too sure
of himself but he wants nothing more
than to be a super he just wants the
world to look up to him that's not a
very good motive for being a super Jimmy
has basically all the same technology
too they both build really advanced
robots but then these robots go crazy
and cause issues that sounds just like
the Omni Droid and The Incredibles now
you might think that Jimmy Neutron and
Syndrome really are the same person
but Jimmy is a Nickelodeon character but
this fan theory suggests that if you
replace Syndrome with Jimmy The
Incredibles movies will turn out exactly
the same
that's how similar they are hmm we think
it's time to binge watch Jimmy Neutron
and The Incredibles government
experiments this fan theory says that
the government gave the supers their
powers this wouldn't be the first time
we have heard of this idea in superhero
lore Captain America anyone but did this
really happen in the world of The
Incredible
here's the evidence first of all the
supers are highly trained on top of
their super powers they basically have
spy skills they can hack computers and
notice tiny details in architecture they
know how to drag and hide bodies and no
one is born knowing how to fly a fighter
jet the idea is that the government
created these heroes to fight crime but
once they were no longer needed and the
plan backfired they dropped the program
then they had the resources to force
them into hiding how would they know who
all the supers are if they didn't create
them why do the kids get superpowers
then well once you change genes those
genes can be passed on
it's a genetic modification but then
this theory gets even darker at some
points there was no need for the supers
where did all the supervillains go the
government got rid of them they purged
them once the super started getting
negative attention the Toy Story
connection a lot of people think that
all the Pixar films exists in the same
universe and there is a lot of evidence
for this in the other movie spot if it's
true where does the Incredibles fit no
other movie has knowledge of superheroes
being real this theory has to do with
syndromes creation of zero-point energy
this is electromagnetic energy that
exists in a vacuum these lasers that are
super advanced are powered by zero-point
energy these lasers are almost capable
of thinking and they are super precise
The Incredibles probably take place
about 50 years before Toy Story what
happened to all this energy after
Syndrome was defeated the theory by
Wattpad user darkness and silent says
that inanimate objects absorbed this
energy it can only be used by non living
creatures so the toys gained their
ability to be alive from this lost
energy whoa that is mind-blowing the
theory goes on to suggests that all the
toys and other machines will rise up and
get rid of humans that seems really dark
and advanced for kids movie but it would
put a link between The Incredibles and
the rest of the Pixar movies syndrome is
the real hero in any story the bad guys
always think they are the good guys
right it's all a matter of perspective
this theory suggests that syndrome is
actually the real hero in The
Incredibles not only that he's working
for the government at the beginning of
the first
we see the supers causing all sorts of
problems they just totally disregard the
safety of everyone else when fighting
crime the government forces them into
hiding but you can just expect supers to
totally give up their identities right
so the government contracts with
Syndrome he's got advanced technology he
can lower less stable supers to his
island to get rid of them that helps
protect society from the danger they
caused and they get to go out doing what
they love
Plus buddy was just a kid when mr.
incredible was a total jerk dam syndrome
also is a champion for the common man he
wants regular people to be able to be
heroic - and just like Batman or Iron
Man he uses his brains to become like a
super the movie gives off the message
that some people are just better than
others and that's just not true in the
end though he was defeated by a whole
family of supers was he really all that
evil Edna mode is a super everyone's
favorite fashion designer might be more
than meets the eye Edna is brilliant she
knows how to design suits for
superheroes these suits can withstand
all sorts of situations that takes a
special kind of genius when she designs
jack-jack suit she knows what sort of
things he needs and his powers haven't
even shown up yet
what if Edna's superpower is being able
to sense powers she can sense what
everyone needs and knows exactly how to
give it to them but then in the second
movie Jack Jack surprises her his suit
works but he leaves her full of
questions
she can't predict what he'll do next he
is basically the only person that has
ever been able to surprise her syndromes
parents who doesn't love a villain
origins story this last theory is
actually two and one it has to do with
who buddy's parents are the first theory
is that his parents are actually two
supers when he is little he idolizes
supers it's almost unhealthy and he is
desperately looking for a father figure
he thinks mr. incredible can be that guy
if he was the child of supers he
probably wouldn't see his parents very
often plus he doesn't have any real
powers but he wants nothing more than to
be a super can you imagine how it would
feel to have superhero parents but no
powers also mr. Incredibles seems to
know buddy's mom pretty well but he
looks a lot like Falange II who could
project sonic fields he also resembles
Appaji who could control gravity other
people think he resembles psyche wave
and universal man these two are the
first to supers that are on syndromes
kill list if he grew up hating his own
parents and all supers of course they
would be the first to go do you think
Syndrome is the son of supers let us
know in the comments that's a wrap
thanks for watching subscribe to the
things for more super videos
[Music]